so i saw that there's a new anime this
season called x arm with a 2.16 rating
on my anime list
a 2.16 out of 10. and i just had to see
what the buzz was about because honestly
i've never seen an anime air in
all the years i've been watching anime
receive a score this horrible
and oh my god this show is absolutely
terrible but at the same time it's so
funny how bad it is
like the show is trying so hard to be
like this cool cop thriller anime
but just fails so hard like there's
honestly some choreography here in this
first fight scene that would be cool
in like an action movie or something but
it just ends up being absolute garbage
because just look at the cgi
dude what is going on the animation is
just so
unbelievably bad look at this scene
right here they didn't even put
any effort in he could literally be
seeing anything right now
who said that you would destroy this and
not join them
okay maybe not that like during this
scene this is what the creators swear
you're saying as you watch it
whoa holy [ __ ] is this the matrix
dude that that kick was so awesome
but in reality this is how it's going oh
what is this why does it look like a
2002 video game cutscene
what are they walking on what is this
[Music]
oh wait that was actually kind of sick
she spent with like the gun still
held in her leg all right all right okay
that was low-key cool
and honestly the funniest thing to me is
how like half the characters are cgi
and then half aren't they're like bottom
of the barrel 2d
normal anime characters like what is
going on in this scene
who thought this was a good idea what
were they thinking when they decided to
make one character cgi and then put him
right next to a character
who's not like even a blind person would
notice the difference between these
characters
and neither is drawn well and look like
you've got the boys walking in here and
then like
why is he the only one who's 2d what is
going on
what about this guy specifically
required him to be flattened into a
single plane
they've also got these like unbelievably
out of place zoom ins that literally
just
increase the scale of the video image so
you're just looking
at like a three pixel image of a school
for some reason
the way they do certain cuts is just so
jarring too like
hold up wait what was that yo go back
why does it go from a zoom out and snap
right to a still frame
what is this for some reason they also
just throw in like some random fan
service every 10 minutes or so
i mean this is fine normally but it's
just so weird in this anime for some
reason
like first the chick tells him
like they knew what they were doing here
and then the way to transfer data is by
like these two chicks making out
and the funniest one was when i was
watching this scene and then just bam
random etchy fan art transition scene
like this was even more surprising than
the full metal alchemist ones where the
dude literally just pops in speaking
english for some reason saying
full metal alchemist like why is this
the transition scene
and why is it drawn better than the rest
of the show like look at the opening
even
like the opening is where the animation
studio normally blows like half their
budget to make some really insane
looking animation to make the show look
cool
but nope it's just the same garbage like
they really couldn't spare
any extra effort to make these scenes
cool and the tragedy is honestly that
the song is actually pretty decent
but any hype that could have been there
is just sucked away by this gameboy
advance level animation
the plot is also just flaming hot
this guy like hates technology for some
reason even though he's a teenager in
high school
and then gets hit by a huge truck and
then gets brought back to life with his
brain in a robot called an
x-arm except the robot isn't some cool
android or like synthetic being
it's literally a briefcase with a skype
webcam attached to it
like dude how are we supposed to have
any emotional attachment to this
character
when his only expressions are seen in
the rotations of a webcam
like wall-e had more emotion than this
guy the show has these shots where like
the voice actor is delivering this
really emotional or surprising line
but then the actual video is just this
box with a robot eye just shaking around
it's like that episode of friends where
joey expects the robot to be a human
android and then it's just a moving hunk
of metal
at least that one could move though like
the main character in x-arm literally
has to be carried around
man is not even mobile there's this
scene where he's supposedly risking his
life for the mission
but in reality he's literally just a
computer processing a bunch of data and
he's overheating
my laptop does this every time i edit a
video man it's not that deep
he's like steaming and they're all going
you hit your limit minutes ago you can't
keep going
and he's like no i have to the actual
line he says is something like
suicide bombings can go to hell who
wrote this script
and so because like x arms are really
rare or something he gets recruited by
the boss of the police and then joins
the police to help
fight crime as a super computer he meets
this girl whose job is to
analyze all kinds of data quote for
quote
dope man i love that job analyzing data
just like
all kinds of data you know how to be
this kind of data that kind of data all
kinds
but then later that episode they need to
look through every camera in tokyo
and you would think that this analyzing
data job would be given to the girl but
nope it's the main character because
there's too much like she got introduced
and did
absolutely nothing she's the tech geek
and she couldn't do
any tech and for some reason the white
hair android chick got some upgrade to
her body which
also came with less clothes again just
to hammer that fan service in which is
really the only saving grace of the show
like watch this scene and try not to
cringe
oh my god what is this animation what is
that face
yo oh yo what where did he go yo
what's come on why is he falling
oh he just got quickscopes
x-arm is just absolutely unbelievable
i've never
seen an anime like this it's honestly
unintentionally funnier than a lot of
comedy anime i've seen
just because of how horrible it is i
i have no words like you guys should
just watch it just for the entertainment
factor it's so funny to watch an anime
just
fail so hard at almost every aspect
the story the characters none of it is
fleshed out and
with an animation like this it's just
it's embarrassing
it's like a car wreck and you cannot
take your eyes off of it throughout
this has been the anime culture corner i
hope you enjoyed the video and i hope
you watch
x-arm right after this don't forget to
like and subscribe for more in-depth
show
manga and character analyses